une salle de classe transformée en
atelier de dessin ces écoliers
apprennent à reproduire une bande
dessinée en quatre vignettes là on était
surtout sur un petit format donc un
redécoupage en quatre cases
donc le but c'était de leur faire
comprendre du coup le sens de lecture
déjà comment placer les bulles et les
placements des personnages aussi qui est
très important et apprendre à gérer son
espace l'espace de travail d'une case
moi je pars du principe que pourra être
capable de raconter une histoire faut
commencer par quelque chose de court et
simple c'est comme une blague on fait
qu'on va contracter le temps est ce que
tu as appris ce matin à bien faire les
dessins des bd aussi à parler dans les
bulles pour ma pour bien les c'est si
important
c'est ça qui est pas facile en fait sur
une planche de bande dessinée c'est de
raconter quelque chose on une seule case
le support utilisé un extrait de la
bande dessinée les petits diables
est ce que tu as des cinémas
la fille qui au delà le garçon qui tombe
dans les treize heures pour y voir un
autre table voici williams en matière de
bande dessinée cet écolier maîtrise déjà
son sujet je vais pas dire que suivant
mais je me dis beaucoup d'écoles et ses
élèves de cm1 ont de la chance leur
enseignante apprécié la bd et le
festival va lui donner l'occasion
d'approfondir un projet festival c'est
le point de départ qui me permet de
travailler sur le vocabulaire de la
bande dessinée sur comment on s'organise
dans une bande dessinée quelle écriture
on utilise quel est le vocabulaire est
approprié et puis à partir de ça et on
va construire ensemble quelque chose
avec les enfants en écrivant
l'imagination des enfants
une bd verra donc le jour avec pour
cadre le château de cheverny
tout un programme